hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pogo stuck I wanted
to play this on my own so that I
wouldn't have to make my friends hate me
is the real crux the issue also I'm
going new controller I practiced a bit
more I have I've practiced and I think
this game I'll be right back closing the
door so I don't bother anyone with
potential screaming I the thing about
this game is it's more predictable than
mehnat fought II it is it's much more
predictable once you learn the nuances
of it and how you move in the world it
gets easier that's not to say it's easy
but it gets easier this is with the the
controller I've got the Xbox controller
here and I'm assuming that it's gonna be
a lot smoother I mean I have practice
with the Xbox control I like it a lot
more you can actually control the
nuances of where the Pogo is facing you
still run into properly it's it's it's a
question of it's question of angles
that's what it is it's a question of
angles so it's like what angle are you
working on how are you gonna use how's
that angle gonna affect your trajectory
you know what I mean like that's what
you got to think about but that's the
only thing that you got to think about
it's a game of angles like that's it if
you got the angles see it's a game of
angles oh it's a game of angles that's
all it is oh I am a god at Pogo suck I
am oh my god I'm a god I am unbelievable
oh yeah I am the best sometimes it grabs
on in ways I don't anticipate ow okay
this is where the rubber meets the road
because I've been here before I've also
fallen off of here before so I don't
want to do that okay down and up okay
angles angles okay here we go no wait
wait
okay we're good we just gotta get no no
no no no don't no don't oh no I'm losing
I'm losing I'm losing height losing
height oh god damn it god damn it okay
all right shut up me how could I turn
the I don't care about no stop I don't
care if it happens but I just don't want
it to happen while I'm no no yes okay
good we're good
we're good we're good we're good we're
good i leveled i Louisville DUP I still
don't know how you get experienced but I
love old so that's good so I just gotta
get through this next part [ __ ] god damn
it oh [ __ ] off it's fine
it's about failure it's about failing
and getting back up on the horse
it's about horsing back up on you know
what I mean
oh [ __ ] back up yes
no god damn back do the same damn thing
over and over again when will I learn
never do the same damn thing I always
make the same damn mistake I'm I am
nothing if not consistent in my error
but that's a good thing because it shows
that I as a player this game am getting
more consistent with my actions which i
think is a good thing okay here we go Oh
what is that
well that distracted that almost made me
fall god damn what is that what how is
the most annoying piece of garbage
effect possible yes thank you that's
what I want oh god oh god I can't see a
goddamn thing it just got a very calmly
there why was that not a boost I don't
know
who stopped being like that okay come on
no no no oh my god here we go here we go
here we go everything's it's a game of
angles it's a game of angles everybody
it's a game oh it's a game of angles and
foix yes yes okay just gotta get up
there oh okay just got it no oh stop
with the new oh god don't pin it don't
pin where am I going
stop I don't want that okay everything's
fine I just get so panicked that's my
problem
it's my only problem are ye oh ye oh ye
oh ye it's my only problem is that I
panic I have no other problems besides
that one problem that was not a boost
oh no fault no not all the way down why
would you go there okay just reach go
okay I don't understand anything but I'm
gonna get no mistake oh god dammit Oh
brick okay this is Oh bah I swear it's
more predictable than Bennet funny it is
it really is I swear it is but at the
same time holy crap angle game of angles
game of angles everybody game of angles
oh yes
no no no no God oh I just hate messing
up like that when I know I can do better
than that it's a good quality of mine
it's a good quality calling me out when
I know I'm not putting in my full effort
I know I'm I was goofing around there at
that time this time why is this not a
boost
oh my god
oh my god there we go
freakin finally see the biggest problem
isn't that it's individually hard it's
that I get so few opportunities to
practice the new stuff because it takes
me so long to get back to where I've
been no that's wrong God oh no it's
right it's right I'm right it's okay
it's all good oh my god I thought I I
thought I just beefed it again oh my
goodness gravy okay and there we go oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god okay all right here we go
and yes yes oh okay all right okay all
right okay all right okay all right okay
all right okay all right that's
interesting I got uh okay I can't see
which is a problem okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay it's a game angles and we
reached it and nope ooh yes okay Oh
okay Oh God God hold it just hold it
holy no where am I I it's fine
okay new area of course is gonna take me
some getting used to so that's just what
this is it's it's a grace period to get
used to all of this jazz that's
happening right here tasty spicy jazz
that okay there's some tasty spicy jazz
that's happening here okay it's a game
of angles it's always more of an angle
than I think it is God unless it's too
much of an angle that I think it is oh
god damn god damn it oh my god I can't
see if I can't see this is just
unnecessary rage this is just
unnecessary it's absolutely unnecessary
I don't need it I don't need it in my
life
I need a Zen there we go there we go I
always get up there on like the first
try that's like it so area it's always
like a first try thing for me okay so
yeah okay how am I supposed to reach em
how am I supposed to reach that I think
I gotta like oh okay well I was on it
okay that's bouncy this isn't so bad
okay that's right on the tippy tippy
edgy wedgie Oh God oh no here we go
Oh God aah
your stupid flabby body it's so stupid
yeah okay so I got it yes okay ah ah
yes no I don't know where it's going
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait way away away away
wait okay by waiting I made myself fault
God I'm alive okay here we go and up and
there we are okay we're back okay I
thought I thought I was so afraid of
losing progress that I saw my
help from gaining progress here we go so
there's definitely Oh God no no no God
I always forget which angle my dangle is
going oh god it's the worst it's yeah
it's the worst god damn it
oh my god I freaking hate that that is
the worst effect I've ever seen in my
life that is the worst yes okay here we
go
God you've I blame you for that god damn
it why is that not a super boost oh my
god I hate everything about this here we
go this is it okay nope never mind here
we go all right here we go okay never
mind I thought that was gonna go there
we go there's what we were talking about
no no god damn
[Music]
god no oh my god I can't fathom I can't
fathom the idea behind blocking the
angles of what I'm facing just oh my oh
my god you bounced me the exact ways
that I can't get to what I need it that
should have been a super that should
that should have been a super No oh god
it's just no God is so painful it's just
so ridiculously painful I can't explain
how painful this experience is okay
Oh God just land on it oh my god oh my
god the world's greatest wall jump now I
could just get on it there we go in up
and back I guess what
oh my god really okay and we're down
this is the most ludicrous thing I've
ever experienced okay there we go there
we go here we go all right we're in it
we're in it rearing it Brandon we're in
it yes okay where am I going
no no no okay wait just let's just hold
a god hold on are you oh no god damn it
oh my god oh my god oh my god just oh I
swear to God I swear okay here we go
just no god damn it [ __ ] God just hold
on just hold on I'm trying to
stop moving okay we're here
god dammit how long is that [ __ ]
music gonna play no not all the way
oh my god okay just just oh god damn it
I can't stop there is the thing that I'm
learning I just can't because if I do
it's disease oh god if I do it spells
death god damn it there we go there no
stop
okay here we go just stop stop okay okay
so what I'm gathering from this is that
I need to jump on to that thing and then
jump straight up that's all I have to do
okay
no God and I [ __ ] it up immediately and
this is going straight down isn't it god
dammit okay get on there and that's not
a boost oh [ __ ]
Oh oh my god I just want to try I know
I'm gonna fail at it I just want to try
it that's all I want to do I just want
to try it
that is why does everyone have that now
I've never seen that a day in my life
and now suddenly a god dammit now
suddenly everyone has that why I don't
[ __ ] know stop being an idiot okay
here we go
I'm just gonna try ha ha okay and we're
back here better than dead I guess I
mean it's not like we're gonna die in
any of this but I mean we're all gonna
die someday me probably sooner than
others depending on how this this game
goes okay ah [ __ ] Christ
well I tried it Waddy died I actually
got to try it and get
what I [ __ ] up just as badly as I did
on everything else here Todd yeah and I
can't get it back up anymore it's just
completely out of my realm of
possibility to even get back up to where
I was I got back up there so many times
and now I just can't I just can't
it's it's impossible for someone such as
me there I go that was my chance and I
[ __ ] squandered it because I'm
bitching and moaning there we go [ __ ]
god damn it if I could just mmm I could
just keep it together for like one god
damn it okay interesting okay
interesting all right we're here which
is interesting how okay that's
impossible
okay that's impossible I thought that
maybe maybe I could just normal jump
there without a super boost but I don't
know what I was thinking nothing can be
done with the normal boost here oh my
god I just want to get back to where I
was that's all I want that's all I want
I just want to get back to work god stop
hating oh my god I swear to god I am
doing god stop okay interesting
maneuvers I'll take it I'll take it you
know I'll take it I'm gonna stop
complaining about what I'm not getting
go ahead and I'm gonna start being
thankful for what it does give me which
is not very much admittedly okay wish I
could see wish I could say wish I could
freaking see what's in front of me there
we go okay here we go all right we're
gonna hit our head gotta go and then
we're gonna yes oh no I know oh my god
no no no no no no oh my god okay I'll
take it oh my god I'll take it better
than what you were about to
to me goddamnit sure wish I could see
[Music]
god damnit
oh my god oh [ __ ] off god no oh oh are
you you guys know this problem already I
get flustered I lose control like fine
motor control and I can't do what I want
to do which makes me more angry and
therefore I get less progress oh my god
just if I could just oh if I could just
okay here we go yes
no God where am I
okay and we're back down [ __ ] I can't
believe some of this [ __ ]
I can't believe it and we're going back
down cuz I can't [ __ ] why was that
not a super God I can't see my angle
it's like it's so goddamn frustrating
because I know that when they play
tested it they're like oh this is one
the players start to get a hang of
things let's mess it up for them let's
ruin all their progress that they feel
like they made as a player of this game
let's just do that I'm gonna go quiet
for a bit because I okay because I just
I just don't really oh my god
I [ __ ] swear to god I [ __ ] swear
to God
I will do nothing I will be patient
that's all time I got for this episode
thank you everybody so much for watching
I'll come back to this I know I can do
it I know I can I don't know why I
wasn't able to do it already
I'll see you the next one bye bye
[Music]